[Musik]
im westen kanada
doch funktion sie große jubiläums reis
beruf und ganz herzlich willkommen sieht
ein jahrzehnt begleiten wir
schweizerinnen und schweizer für ihre
suche nach abenteuer und auch eine neue
heimat und ich bin im moment kanada
unterwegs und das kann zufall will
kanada ist das wohl ein schlechter tag
an anderen orten so viel begleitet ihr
dort unter anderem mit mir im boot sitzt
das ehepaar wir das kleinen ort erworben
kanada ist da hast du geld aus als noch
kennt niemand genau
nikotin ist was im reservat werde
zufrieden mit dem man während der
hermann schönbächler holzpfeiler und
familie vater ist bekannt ist von der
auswanderer
er sagt selber dort kanada seine
bestimmung zugeführt worden
bei hermann hat viel von seinen treuen
verwirklichen aber eine geht es gleich
noch als leben sowie der ab vom schuss
komplett auf sich allein gestellt
das war als coolste machen woran
passieren für zwei jahre nimmt es der
hermann mit easy mitglieder die wildnis
[Musik]
und noch viel mehr hat für sie der
jubiläumssendung auf die große reise
durch kanada
die auswanderer vor frühere straflager
besucher sind sind die geschichte vom
großen glück und nicht weniger große
existenzängste
mit dem ganzen als speziell zeigen mit
ganz neuen auswanderer abend die
[Musik]
funktion stinktier bei hand fuß wanderer
wo sich widerlegt stadt zählende volk
multimodal sein können begleitet
mein gefühl mehr witze ein solcher
leider kann ich von mir steht drüber
ganz neue geschichte
das buch krieg sie wo mir und das ist
ein großes gefühl
und am schluss bringe man ein
überraschungsgast in kanadische walter
köhler vom titelsong trifft zum ersten
mal auf der hermann schönbächler
das ist sehr jung und tv
und sie spiegeln
[Musik]
rosewood westkanada familie schön bleibt
wie das aber noch nicht genug für die
hermann
wer kann auch wirklich wähler leben für
sie und wildnis und dienst war es dann
einmal mit das ist als fußballer
überhaupt nicht aber es ist sicherlich
genau gut also dass nicht nur mit den
echten bewaffnet ist mit was ich habe
mit sting cinema nicht spree mit
das ist aber dass die liebe wo vor allem
das ist sehr dick wird disco erledigen
da geht es folgendermassen aber
beschlossen habe wirklich packen ganz
schnell wieder mit dem gespräch geht es
schlecht
der herr manisch auf alles vorbereitet
und die machen mich glaubt schon mal auf
alles gefasst mir zweiter in val d'or
und die heilung geht christine bechtel
zum rechten und zu den 31 natascha wifi
und alexandra goga ferien
wir sind vor ort ufer in richtung norden
zum feind lake
[Musik]
da auf der anderen seeseite liegen
hunderte quadratkilometer wald voraus
als wort
ja ja ja ja
[Musik]
so sieht also dass kanada wurde hermann
am liebsten leben im blockhaus wieder
wildnis sowie pionier frühen 18
das war's coolste wochen wochen
passieren
damit haben wir hier in zwei mehr oder
weniger als beim walken aus regen aus
ich hatte hier gründer schon als kleiner
bub peter herrmann für rupert wildnis
verschlungen
was ihn so fasziniert oder einsame natur
und wir nur irgendwann gerne mal über
genau das will ist hermann jetzt zeigen
[Musik]
die motive gottwald kein plan oder
landet
[Musik]
endlich findet man als plötzlich das
basislager
das müssen wir ja
sie wollte sich die scheibe
ja
ist
[Musik]
aber ich glaube ich habe es mal nicht
nur vorstellen wenn der platz leer pro
grab bliebe also wäre das ein platz wo
du es wir stehen aber schön sowas nicht
hier ist hauptsächlich das was hier
gebaut verstecken
also sagen wir arbeiten wir bei weg.de
fakten fakten fakten
ja wir müssen
[Musik]
sie packt
der star sei ihm nicht lang mit
[Musik]
jesionek session nicht so ein bisschen
durch nestlé und flechten von boeing als
zünder
und dann packte hermann sie magnesium
für status ist 14 nicht einfach wenn das
gas wird sie genau sie stets nicht das
geht auch ins masters magnesium wird das
tut überzeugt
wusste vorher will der hermann als
üblich hoch so sieht auch grafik
mitnehmen
so und das wasser trinken
das sorgt immer so wie sie jetzt auch
hier im schnitt bringt wieder hier bei
denen orte wo bitte ist das bakterium
momentan einfach es ist ja die boots vor
bestimmte sorte denn wenn das uwc der
muss im spitalhof
zum glück war mit 95 minuten die biber
knapp drüber
[Musik]
lepper und überleben in der natur musste
hermann lehre als junge marga buch
alando kanada und alaska ist
ganz alleine unterwegs bist doch wunsch
aus wo eigentlich lieber mit seiner
partnerin wenn die reise aus
mutterseelenallein und selbst örtlich
hat mit niemandem teilen um sogar dass
wir tag für tag durch die schönste sache
doch das wort teenager drauf hast mit
niemandem teilen
das macht dich fertig das machte tätig
darum stellte der menschliche darum
stellte den menschlichen gebrauch celtic
dass der liebe gott aus meinen blick
macht es ganz logisch
die große liebe mit der alles teilen
kann fand hermann schönbächler in seiner
frau christine
sie ist ebenso begeistert von der natur
und von kanada im speziellen
es passt perfekt nur einmal im leben
macht der mann einen größer anfangen als
mit christine
[Musik]
zum ihrem größten abenteuer brechen die
beiden in 2010 auf
sie wandern aus von biel nach kanada
ballaballa
kostenpunkt des hauses 250000 franken
die reise war lang und am ende wartet
ein viertes kaltes haus auf die kranke
natascha
[Musik]
die familie macht sich vertraut mit der
neuen lg handy
[Musik]
sie kommen
kaputt
womit sich korrekt
der gelernte forstwart hermann
schönbächler hat eine anstellung als
holzfäller erhalten
sein boss ist angetan von den
fähigkeiten seines neuen mitarbeiters
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nun an kann die familie schönbächler
ihre abenteuerlust direkt vor der
haustüre ausleben
[Musik]
allerdings das boot hält mit der
euphorie von hermann nicht ganz mit und
warum heißt der umstieg vom ball
[Musik]
anfangs sommer kommt jeweils der bart ab
ein ritual das hermann mit den jahren
aber bleiben lassen
[Musik]
ja
am 10 10 2010 kommt die nacht welche die
familie schönbächler nie mehr vergessen
wird
ein jahrhundert sturm zieht auf
bäume knicken wie zündhölzer und ruhen
auf das neue zuhause das schönbächlers
zu fallen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das haus bleibt zum glück unbeschädigt
aber die zerstörung im wald ist riesig
da hier
das ist das was sie mit großer einzige
einzigen
2 warum das das letzte nach nur zwei
monate später gibt es erfreuliches zu
berichten
die familie schönbächler ist komplett
das nicht unbedingt wählen und ja dieses
dafür dass ich das ist schön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hermann hinblick der baumfäller weiß ein
gefühl der freude ihn ein kerniges
lebensmotto zu gießen
[Musik]
auch fünf jahre später ist die
verwüstung des sturmes noch deutlich
sichtbar
doch die naturkatastrophe hat auch ihr
gutes
dank der vielen brachliegenden bäume
konnten sich schönbächlers als
holzlieferanten selbstständig machen in
der nächstgelegenen stadt terrors gehen
die beiden kinder regie und natascha
mittlerweile in die schule
sie haben einen sehr langen schulweg von
drei stunden
[Musik]
die fünfjährige alexandra ist noch zu
hause
die schönbächlers haben es sich gut
eingerichtet doch ein kleiner von
abenteuerlust scheint noch nicht
gestillt
die matif traum weiß vielleicht schon
mal können sich ganz ganz nah aber
durchsetzen
[Musik]
und durfte spuren vor dem ultimativen
traum wurde hermann und stine träumt sie
mir jetzt
[Musik]
doch im wald mit dem hermann wie davor
der zivilisation
einsam nur mir und das barocke so
hoffnungsvoll um sich greife
[Musik]
weil das zonen unter gott wird zum
kolleg
die putzfrauen jetzt hilfe vogel.de
damit ist das buch das nicht
ich hoffe ich mache jetzt ist nicht die
zeit der hermann hat sie stylt vitrine
im waldorf bau wäre mir sie der nacht
krank strafe doch seit die säge ddr
jahres sieht nur dumme normal hieß
das spiel eines quer das schlauchte dem
schlaf gut
während mir im wald langsam weg de
france wird ohne große aufregung und
christine schönbächler via facebook
erfahren dass immer noch bei einem
schlief und zwar nicht irgendeiner
sondern in como die das ganz besonders
das ist eine von einer wiese vor zwei
bedeutungen hand ganz selten ist eine
von einer feier am albis
ihr hat er zwei ausgesetzt und darum ist
das richtig speziell jetzt selber der
bauten im jahr da und ihren 125
vor der tür
bewegte unterschreibt im gebüsch so
geht's nicht
so versteht
[Musik]
ich bin bei nicht stören
so lästig
wie der uno ist aegis ebay heilig sie
das heißt er bringt eine glück wohnen
gesehen
[Musik]
bush camp ist alles ruhig geblieben
nur recht keltisches worden
ich probiere für zu machen der autoriese
[Musik]
mehr
mini survival skills lange schiff ihren
warmen haferbrei und für ein buschkow
wieder hermann und nur bis anhin braten
spezielle deutsche haltung der hermann
hätten noch wie suv geburtstag alles
alles gute
die herzliche ausblasen mitziehen so
dankbar für das ist lustig sein kann tag
wird eine andere
bis 25 wichtig ist dass das ist dass ich
das ich spüre ich hoffe da hierdurch das
ist
unter kilometer und kilometer im bus
shuttle service
[Musik]
für ihre dritte hermann sind geburtstag
einfach ko fische oder allein im wald
das eintrittsalter chöre begegnungen mit
wilden tieren zu der hermann gott auf
seine ganz eigene art mit ihnen um
also meistens mit mit mit schwarz beide
wohl irgendwie soll im bereich 20 50
meter oder so abhängig eine application
for a moment redet nur über weniger
herceg novi aber nur wenn ich doch ganz
ich gar nicht hätte gar keine lust hätte
zu vielen spielern oder wo das irgendwie
gar nichts ist territorium woche
strittig machen nur so erwarte das
machst du aber gleich ne yo langsam
winter stellen schweizer tisch oder tut
man lange ich das auch morgen im ersten
semester
[Gelächter]
der grund wieso mir dort muss kurz
stören
der hermann zu echtes plötzlich ohne
blues ist lockruf bauen
das täten alles kindes zu 1 ausglich
da ist gut verlaufen diese woche lang
verzweifelt putzt du diesen gefunden
wurde
fruchtbare boden ist das oder hermann
sucht ist weniger lkws bauen muss ich
also schön in amerika
wir sind unterwegs mit pionier der schon
vor 100 jahren rufen davor sind und die
kanadische wildnis in kopie siedle
humors stehen der hermann grub im
gegenteil ich das gefühl je länger oder
sucht umso ernster wir zum damit der
umsatz mit der wildnis das heimat ruft
stelle auf die suche ja das ist mit das
ist mir wichtig ist es mir wichtig ist
mord
das danach auf die spiele ist ja
irgendwie führte schlaganfalls ist das
ist ja passiert dass ich als jede
messerscharfe klingen aber um nummer
braucht aber im rock bis wir jetzt auch
lea welle gruppe dunkle kontinent die
machen ja also nicht das dunkel
rauschens lag bei 20
[Musik]
herold
als pionier vier bräuten packt jetzt
wieder hermann grundriss von block cruz
lecker so quasi als geburtstagsgeschenk
für sich selber
drei auf drei meter vor der
alterssiedlung meistens sie bei hermann
schätzt dass rapper 14 wir brauchen zum
sohnes blockhausbau und dann der
schweizer wald krimi sich darum dass man
die hand
er forscht ewig also das wäre so
grundfläche
das war es auch grundfläche quadrat da
muss schon mehr biss und dokus kleid und
damit das fundament von herman simm
traum vom leben in der wildnis
wunderschöne kindheit mit sich selbst
stehen irgendwo im selben zimmer gehängt
leider oder zum glück umstand der augen
wie das sicherste helga trettin busses
juni normal
ja absolut
im hermann traurig sei absolut zu dass
er sich irgendwann das alter überhaupt
ob für sehr steht gott druck zu hoch und
familie france mit
regel macht pancakes thema nummer eins
ist richtlinie ihre begegnung mit dem
commodity man wirklich in die 10
darum haben dank des musters
[Musik]
wie gut ist die high von der schon
beschlossenen abenteuerspielplatz wo
sich jeder fan muss leben
das meinte herrmann vermutlich mit
ultimativer lebensqualität
fürsorge dehnte sich zum großen teil
selber mit fleisch eier gemüse und
früchte
doch zum ablassen sogenannten es sind
sommerferien und auch kind helfen mit
beim ferien vorbei sind gott nur noch
die jungs steht alexandra wester mache
berichtet christine von der neuigkeit
mit familie schönbeck natascha und der
risiken über die öffentliche schule
sondern werden unterrichtet
wenig später nach der verehrer dann
machst du da homeschooling warum
[Musik]
menschen diese schon nah aber denkt
station die kollegen von der schule will
dass das untere mich also wie viel will
aber kollege sind wichtig und er
erstellt werden er hat freunde tross am
wochenende noch nicht einig die große
die stanze ist homeschooling kanada
verbreitet transporter mit der aufgabe
kontrolliert so gesehen kanadische
schulabschluss
aktiv zu acht hackett sei christine aber
ab der oberstufe sex lerntempo dolphy
langsam rassiges natascha immer mehr
studiert sie sieht immer jung für die
halle muss aber ersten entscheid oder
entscheidet wie ich gemacht ohne dass
ich etwas mit der tasche das ist ein
längerer prozess sie war schließlich
immer unglücklicher wurde nicht in der
schule
ich sage das ganz anders sieht beginnt
in hua strengen unter zwischen dinge ich
sehr gute hilft das ist schön und ich
meine kinder dass sie das ist ein
musiker zusammen um mannschaft zusammen
und man machtlos gemüse zieht
miteinander bis kind irgendwann ihren
eigenen treuen augen und ausflüge
[Musik]
für mich wird zum aufbrechen
zum 10 jahr jubiläum fund v dc 3 andere
auswanderer familie zu besuchen
große reise wo mich am schluss noch mal
zurück zur schönbächlers führt
wenn dir wüste tweer sie da noch
ungebrochen
[Musik]
denn die genannte mitprägt aber etwas
aus warmbach sondern mit ihrer musik
boeing-titel anrufen bevor das gefühl
von w&v weg wählen so perfekt wie
möglich ist
[Musik]
groß ist
wir gehen
[Musik]
mit dem gewinn überraschend zurück
familie fischer wo 2014 vor der familie
folgt der achten staffel
und familie ruckstuhl homo vorjahr
[Musik]
im roßwog general store eine einzige
weit und breit pfaffinger proviant mit
einem lader finden alles nötige zum
leibe und als regal mit sp2 nickel
lebenswichtige
[Musik]
das ist eine spezialität
ja wenn wir zum beispiel ist der komet
am barren mit dpa mit einer riesen knall
motto dieses werk für werk zum wäre
vergrämen und normal bis klee und über
kanadier und ihren umgang mit der
wildnis aber jetzt zum wird die
kanadische tellerrand duselige 17 jahre
begleitet und auf das wir sind noch am
abend ihr oder noch mehr neue heimat und
die derzeit 90 bis 100 die vom menschen
beworben aber begleitet haben natürlich
nur der kleinste teil von ihnen könne
jetzt ist eine jubiläumssendung die
ideale lassen opel ist auch für andere
anfragen gibt die ihren traum
verwirklichen und ich glaube und klären
denn die dänen zahlen dass das es nie so
etwas planen
aber das ist dann gab es so an der
schule und wirbelte familie fluri da
schon doch speziell
familie fluri das sind kathrin und
christopher mit ihren drei kindern anja
sami und jannis eine stinknormale
familie könnte man meinen
vor sieben jahren trafen wir sie zum
casting in neuheim kanton zug
und wenn wir damals gewusst hätten was
die flur ist für abenteuer erleben
werden
hätten wir sie schon früher begleitet
[Musik]
australien ist ihr großer traum
die floris verkaufen ihr haus und ihre
reinigungsfirma
doch plötzlich ziehen sie die reißleine
sie blasen australiens premiumweg
riskieren dass grundsätzlich ist der
umgang her und jetzt aber wird die neue
waren die ece und mehr den user und
haben wir uns dazu entschieden das
anders auslegen darf bin ich drauf hab
vor phau nach rom zurück macht den schuh
vorgezogen und dennoch
[Musik]
kathrin und christopher wissen nichts
über dieses land gar nichts trotzdem
entscheiden sie sich eine woche nach
südamerika zu reisen
ist das extrem gut von textern und dank
das können wir uns gut vorstellen
offizier und haben das gemacht zieht das
hus kraft und die ganze planung bleibt
und es ist das jahr 2013 familie fluri
hat nach dem verkauf von haus und würmer
genügend geld um für längere zeit ohne
einkünfte auszukommen
alle genießen die zeit in hubei die
kinder gehen zur schule und sind schnell
integriert und auch die einheimischen
tiere hinterlassen einen bleibenden
eindruck
ein baby stinktier läuft der familie zu
your hätte mich angespritzt betrieben
auch will die sind sehr schreckhaft oder
und schwante mir das ufer und der grund
da spritzt das geht ja so sind die
tröpfle unter stinkt intensiv man sogar
ganz oben mit zement oder natürlich
gemerkt dass meine burkhard da haben wir
den etat der stadt wie so matlok und da
herrscht generieren und dann ist das
nicht das erkennen auch ein funktionär
steckt in der hand
floris sind glücklich in uruguay endlich
haben sie zeit für sich es gibt nur ein
problem
kathrin und christopher finden keine
möglichkeit zu arbeiten
durch trio ist es ist einfach alles
gemacht um geld wähler machen um das tor
herum ist in mir sind auch die viele und
mir hand ging sofort wieder neu ist auch
ein angesagter knappe woche
und so ziehen die flores in die
vereinigten staaten ins sonnige florida
nicht etwa ans meer sondern ins
hinterland
hier liegt das rentner paradies
schlechthin der bridges die stadt wurde
speziell für rentner aus dem boden
gestampft eigene straßen für golf buggy
inklusive zehntausende rentner leben in
the villages die nächste größere
ortschaft heißt lady lay
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mitten im altersheim von amerika die
auswanderer familie fluri mit ihren drei
kindern ja dass die xantener so ich
empfinde das hätte so den vorteil will
alles ist sehr gepflegt und ordentlich
der hofball schöne klatsche in die
rechte an
er findet dass dieser punkt die familie
wohnt ein wenig außerhalb von lady lay
stadt australien nach uruguay und weiter
nach florida
die flure stellten gleich mehrmals alles
auf den kopf
was trieb sie an ihr leben so radikal
umzukrempeln
jetzt machen die definiert sind dass sie
ruhig hin zu groß sind
[Musik]
der garten der flores ist fast so groß
wie drei fußballfelder seeanstoss
inklusive und ein paar alligatoren
sollen sich auch darin tummeln
von nachbarn keine spur morgens um
sieben tag machen für die 2 die brote
ist papa christopher zuständig
die karte kann email
[Musik]
die ernährerin der familie ist jetzt
kathrin kathrin arbeitete schon seit
frühester jugend im restaurant ihrer
eltern mit und lernte hotelfachfrau
jetzt hat sie ein eigenes geschäft eine
eisdiele
sie bezahlte 99 1000 dollar und da hilft
dafür ein laufendes business das eis
stellt sie nicht selber her
sie kauft es ein
kathrins angestellte sind alles frauen
die meisten studentinnen
das geschäft ist gewinnbringend und
sicher der familie die
aufenthaltserlaubnis in den vereinigten
staaten
während katrin die brötchen verdient
schmeißt christopher den haushalt das
macht man nicht so viel los dass ich
einfach das größte gebirge los
christopher musste erst darum kämpfen
den haushalt so führen zu können wie er
will und kann
also wenn ich deine woche und der
bismarck im osten hat das stimmt
vielleicht ne roman der nation ziel so
wenig machen und dann wenn sie so war es
auch im schlaf und ich bin ein taxi am
kochen so und so und da haben wir gesagt
nur zur brust der hoch jetzt mache ich
nichts mache und aber das hat sie gut
gespielt ich kraft thema mehr
die kinder gehen in die öffentliche
primarschule seit zwei jahren in den usa
kommen sie schon gut mit dem englischen
zurecht und seine schwester anja gehen
beide in die fünfte klasse
katrin hat gleich neben der ice tigers
sogar ein zweites geschäft übernommen
die spezialität beim sandwich schlagen
willst du hunger improved
die floris wolle nicht mehr von
ersparnissen leben sondern von ihrem
einkommen damit sie auch im alter noch
rücklagen haben
der richter fragt ihn gewartet dass es
zur wirklichkeit
es ist alles okay auch christopher hat
mittlerweile einen kleinen verdienst
seit kurzem arbeitet er bei einer
biologischen baumschule nicht weil er
muss sondern weil er will sein chef ist
ein franzose unter europäern seien die
mentalitätsunterschiede weniger groß
sagt christopher jetzt wissen sie
bescheid
wir sind sehr bescheiden so herzog
jetzt siehst du ich glaube nicht
thermisch und für die muss laufwagen ist
problemlos mit dem natürlich ist damit
ein nachdem ihr sowie shoutbox
aber die musiker bis zum 24
[Musik]
wenn die kinder um halb vier von der
schule kommen ist mama kathrin bereits
wieder zu hause
[Musik]
sie ist stolz auf die leistungen ihrer
sprösslinge integriert
[Musik]
die flures bereiten in ihrem riesigen
garten ein barbecue vor
[Musik]
der ausgebildete forst wo hat
christopher will holz zerkleinern
wenn ich eine zu bringen
[Musik]
die auswanderung hat die familie noch
mehr zusammengeschweißt
insbesondere weil es gar nicht so
einfach ist hier in den usa neue freunde
zu finden
schweiz usa 2 man auswandern in nur
sechs jahren und trotzdem floris haben
noch nicht genug
plötzlich was mit der idee das dauert in
der usa auto ausbricht ist zur isar
großen zeit suchen und verschiedene
landschaften hier
aber christopher und kathrin wissen auch
dass es für die kinder nun wichtig ist
einmal wurzeln schlagen zu können
also vertragen die beiden abenteurer ihr
fernweh
[Musik]
liebe grüße und zwar jetzt
die profis betreuen
ich bin unterwegs zu der familie fischer
wovon fünf jahre berufen wurde biggs ist
annett und kulturellen user finden was
lebensunterhalt mit lebens williams lake
verändert sich landschaft radikal
[Musik]
storno alles grün denn handbuch land
verheerende waldbrand getötet
[Musik]
brennt sind immer euro zum kurs von der
familie fischer bis zu dem punkt was für
ihre ganze existenz bedroht hat
[Musik]
auf der erste blick zb fisches alles
normal
die weiteren paul und christin spielt im
garten der junge appenzeller bläss sie
verschlucken was du die welt aber mehr
gefahren sind oder auch brent bis zu
einem dorf an
ja sowieso dass da alles bio
das ist ja ich trage sie außer meter
lange und händler muss es also sektor
asche vom himmel gefallen und denn der
weg ist für wirklich jetzt sind wir
gegangen sind
als ergebnis hat familie fischer chief
prägt
[Musik]
ok
jetzt kurt iphone schaffen
[Musik]
seine chance das freut mich sehr
willkommen
wahnsinn sie auch es ist viel gelaufen
ja sagt marita letzte floss weniger
streng vorgestellt das mit dem move
trans das ist ein crash mit dem
traunsteiner überhaupt nicht da
[Gelächter]
da und es führt löschen
naja und durch dass das so heftig sie
wie ihr du eigentlich den hilflos bis
nur noch zulegen
[Musik]
juli 2010 wald brennt breitet sich
zwischen kanadas wegen der trockenheit
buchs nur ein funke features für noch
gewitter mit blitz schlägt rundum
williams lake grad eines bar stelle
gleichzeitig brände und sie vermitteln
als profi zu sonnen
[Musik]
davos wo sie so viel herzblut trägt 10
uhr gezogen
[Musik]
november 2013 familie fischer zieht in
ihr neues zuhause ein
[Musik]
freude bei den kindern bauen und
christian lange haben fischers nach
diesem haus gesucht
rund 350000 franken hat es gekostet
[Musik]
hier haben die fischers mehr platz als
noch in staufen kanton aargau in der
schweiz führten sie eigentlich ein gutes
leben
abgesehen davon dass code als
selbstständiger zu viel zeit in seiner
schreinerei verbrachte
und da war noch dieser wunsch
auszuwandern bei kurt seit seinem kanada
aufenthalt in jungen jahren
irgendwann sagte annett schließlich ja
dort ist ausgebildeter zimmermann wie in
kanada hat er nun einen job in der
königsdisziplin der ingenieurs- kunst
mit holz im blockhausbau
[Musik]
für kurt der traumberuf alle häuser
werden auf dem firmensitz zuerst
konstruiert und aufgebaut dann wieder
komplett auseinander genommen und am
endgültigen standort wieder
zusammengesetzt in dieser zeit ist gut
dann bis zu zwei wochen lang weg von zu
hause
[Musik]
eine anstrengende arbeit besonders für
den rücken
[Musik]
eine spezialität von kurz arbeitgeber
holzskulpturen aller art die fix am
blockhaus montiert will
leitung dahin
[Musik]
wenn kurt nicht gerade auf montage ist
verbringt die familie nun mehr zeit
miteinander als noch in der schweiz die
fischers führen ein zufriedenes leben
mit kleinen schwierigkeiten
powell führt zum aller ersten mal
alleine mit dem schulbus zur schule
[Gelächter]
annett fährt mit dem auto nach nur um
sicher zu gehen als sie bei der schule
ankommt keine spur von paul
sie fragt bei der lehrerin nach haben
sie power gesehen nein ich weiß nicht wo
er ist vielleicht ist er im schulbus
geblieben ist er hier nie angekommen
nein am besten gehen sie zu hector
williams wo ist hier normalerweise bei
den schulbussen
bald wird nun richtig nervös paul kann
kaum ein wort englisch ist der womöglich
falsch ausgestiegen oder gar nicht haben
sie vielleicht paul gesehen
nein wer sollte ein tier sei
vielleicht ist er im schulbus geblieben
im bus geblieben ich weiß nicht
jedenfalls ist der nicht ihr okay lasst
uns die busfahrer anrufen
[Musik]
hallo ich suche ein erstklässler der
vielleicht im bus geblieben ist
mal nachschauen er heißt paul er ist ein
neuer schüler
dort liebt es eben mit dem schulbus zu
fahren
altfeld ins busdepot um pauli abzuholen
er ist okay ist nur sehr traurig die
busfahrerin hat ihn hinter dem sitz
nicht gesehen
[Musik]
ja auch gut
die familie fischer schämt ihr glück
gefunden zu haben
[Musik]
bist waldbrand frohsinn briefe vom wind
wasser sonne
november abgeschlossen mit dem ganzen
boni die vc hatte für wanderer ist zu
hoch und so blieb ich stehen
[Musik]
deutsche schwere momente also ich glaube
dass das nie vergessen
und das stellt mich jedes mal wenn ihr
die bilder wieder zu ihnen und dann
macht
[Gelächter]
und ich weiß nur mist in tornados
golfhotels bronze abfahrt und die luchse
und das ist komisch wenn du mal und
[Musik]
schoss vor schluss im protein entstand
ein anderer klub dezember zeit um ihr
wichtig
familie fahrt führe zum zentralen punkt
vom dorf wo es auf andere flüchten die
treffen ein paar reserven so schlecht
wurde und ich mir vorstelle so finde ich
zum beispiel bosco schwerer kost und
quartier im rufe die welt unsere ist
englisch und die luft so schlimm
dortmund
[Musik]
so gesehen also wo man nach dem see
verbracht hat datenschutz der not also
die nicht gesagt zurück macht die ganz
nach nähe und der schaufel studieren was
ich jetzt ein mentor wirklich 1000
ersten moment erzeugt hat immer
roccatune familie fischer findet
unterschlupf bei freunden auf reform der
wind ist entscheidend wenn die treibt
ist akut bedroht
[Musik]
lösch flugzeugflügel pausenlos
frühbucher gottes für endlich unter
kontrolle sind
drei wochen zittern bis familie fischer
wieder zurück als die high
[Musik]
hat man angst da sein da jederzeit
wieder passieren dass merck schon mal
weniger glück aber wenn ich als wähler
oder so
jedes mal wenn der flüge ist es zu früh
im rahmen des logos und einstimmig die
scheibe sparsam riskiert die wichtigste
dokument macht das durchs leben und das
macht jede von ihnen leben als williams
lake auf sand
[Musik]
die features schreibt am morgen nicht
google sondern hochlandrind morgen
routine
was früher selbstverständlich abgespult
entscheidet sie hat vielmehr nicht nur
ein großer für fischers entzweit die
proben wir sind immer stolz
der code ist nämlich woche lang
arbeitsunfähig sie und als schließlich
sind traumjob müssen oft eher farblos
zum neuen arbeitsort und annett gott in
garsten jedem morgen sie die ausbilder
die gärtnerei und ehemalige lehrerin an
einer landwirtschaftsschule setzt ihre
süße hat praktisch in der schweizer
klinik art account da an ich bin zum
ausgleich gemacht zum schulkind zu und
da und da ich mit job und dauern ich
doch auch produzieren
also das ist der lohn aus dem garten
besonders wichtig solidarität wurde
co-trainer schaffen dass ich ihn kurz
neuen arbeitsort ließ es holt süße
unserem blog hofbauer ist ein büro gummi
worden
topline am computer zeichnet und doch
ist der court jetzt happy mit der
situation wenigstens hätte keine
schmerzen im rücken die herde auf der
baustelle ist tief in die bandscheibe
[Musik]
schmerzmitteln
durch das komitee operieren position
gelangen vom sofa plagen und weglaufen
nicht so gelaufen wie noch zum doktor
und akupunktur und sichert runco
operieren oder neben den tischen
wellenmuster barriere aber es hat eine
bessere ich gehe eigentlich da los war
wurde nach der operation money sozusagen
crash monika aber der tochter entmannt
die zeigt also wenn die menschen immer
wenn etwas schlimmes schicksal als gut
mit ihnen gemeint der capitals gewann
der schweizer bauunternehmen sagte sieht
er konstruiert der plan am computer das
gleiche wie er selber hofstetter ist
aber natürlich nur auf der fahrt aldi
arbeitsort von kobe
ja man genug ich noch nicht mit wehmut
über den und danken
[Musik]
der betrieb eines sehr interessant sie
uns wenig gedanken was machen sie
eigentlich und daraus jetzt immer haben
sagte peter und das müssen wir das beste
daraus machen
sind ganz klug sie können die süden
einfach vorwärts jorge familie fischer
jetzt über dem zweimaligen stehen zu dem
spiel gestanden
der verlust von arbeit und so die
riesige waldbrand
zweimal hätte sich auf geordnet und
weitergemacht
[Musik]
ganz ohne körperliche gott im korb ein
doch nicht die sind erneut sehr grimmige
werkstatt oder selber baut hat oder
besser selber hat villa bauen
alles ist vorbereitet sie zum aufstellen
aber den hut ziehen rück gestreikt
dann sind kurz in die block
fußballfreunde helfen und werkstatt in
2d gebaut dass der korb nur im haushalt
helfen ist wer statt dauer mal
professionell wenn nutze ich noch nicht
aber für den ruhm open am schopf 1
konkrete pläne
wenn es bei dem breakfast die richter ja
das war hier raus doch die haie
schwimmen ist dafür aufstellen faust
denn das alles bei dem breakfast mit der
kugel eine hollywoodschaukel trier
ich glaube mit noch selber gab durch
nicht so langer zeit ist wurde eine
wenig macht das bestimmt eine innere
stimme geben wenn es da eine fertig ist
ich komme damit reagiert der hopper der
heute neu bauen
hierzu sagt ihr vergnügen
jetzt gebrochen
[Musik]
mit dem wachsen des infiziert wunder
also dass er überhaupt noch lebt
doch und stifte von gelb über
[Musik]
ein verrückter johanniter website the
movies tötet war sie so alles erwartet
wärme viel ich ausgewandert des acc ruf
und das obwohl menge muss wanderer
gehört und gleichzeitig am schluss alle
sie segelt froh dass das machten
[Musik]
mini reich gottes bar 100 km unserer
nächsten auswanderer familie
und da wäre stellung normal über der
kanadische horizont aussieht für ganz
neue auswanderer geschichte ausgewählt
wusste vielen bewerbungen im besitz von
ikonen erzählen zu rufen da wo einmal
ganz viel familie begleitete anderen und
berlin auf kanada
und wenn man das projekt gemeinsam
anpackt dann macht richtig viel mut aber
wenn es denn nur allein macht oder gott
wo man aus wie sie frau die absolute
exoten ist ein bugrad neue spitzel mehr
im süden des senegals in der stadt cdu
hier hin verschlägt es keine touristen
und es gibt kein internationales
business der einzige mensch weißer
hautfarbe ist hier die schweizerin marie
11 unter fließend wasser und strom gibt
es in dieser region noch fast nicht so
holt die 54 jährige maria ihr wasser
jeden tag frisch am quartier brunnen
erst kürzlich ist sie in ein neues haus
gezogen
vorher hat sie noch viel einfacher
geliebt mit 15 erwachsenen und ebenso
vielen kindern in zwei häusern
es ist nicht unbedingt bequem und
komfortabel aber morgen mit fotos
eigentlich aus geht ganz einfach
kennengelernt haben wir marielle futter
vor fünf jahren
wir besuchten sie damals für ein casting
mit der kamera in meisterschwanden
kanton aargau schwer vermisst haben
sicher viele familien aber mit zu seinem
auto mit roma
und das ist schon nicht einfach so
loslassen
ich bin da capo vaticano im süden
zwischen raucher und irgend ein bisschen
medien
dort ist es wenn sie jetzt noch oft
genau wo bin ich hier ganz schöne
kontakt kam
und irgendwann ist kult doch in dieser
saison in mir schlummert
einfach so der gedanke dass ich irgendwo
auf die kinder unterstützen
foto bild herr irgendwo im land bist du
etwas nicht so gut wie louis jacobi und
übelbach später durch die elektrogeräte
zwar jetzt natürlich geister und heftig
verliebt ist und gesehen kommentar
und ich hab gehört und da und du hast
dass ich dabei allerlei khalifa aber
tatsächlich so dass ich hier eigentlich
verliert kann auf die afrika und die
glied und in senegal
nun wohnt marielle im senegal
mittlerweile hat sie auch einen partner
den 46 jährigen ella statt um katzen
kümmert marielle sich nun um die hunde
ihres partners vor vier jahren ist
marielle in den senegal ausgewandert und
es waren sehr kräfteraubend der jahre
für sie trotz der großen unterstützung
von ella nun stehen die stressigsten
tage ihrer ganzen auswanderung bevor
1964 in muri zur welt gekommen wuchs
marielle als jüngstes von vier kindern
auf nach einer ausbildung als malerin
fand sie ihre berufung schließlich als
kindergarten lehrerin
obwohl sie selber gerne kinder gehabt
hätte hatte das leben anderes mit ihr
vor sie wanderte schon einmal aus und
lebte sechs jahre in mittelamerika
zurück in der schweiz arbeitete sie
wieder als kindergärtnerin
doch da war die suche nach mehr sinn in
ihrem leben
also setzt sie das projekt um das schon
länger in ihr schlummerte sie gründet
den gemeinnützigen verein kinder
goldenes vorsänger mit spenden lehrgeld
und herzblut baut marielle einen ersten
kindergarten in einer abgelegenen region
des landes
der hintergrund überraschend krim cent
wären wir sind engagiert kind entwickelt
sich also vor dem handy sagen ziel
erreicht und das seiner mutter endlich
in den garten in angriff zu nehmen
marielle stürzt sich wieder in die
arbeit zwei jahre ist die
kindergärtnerin und bauleiterin
organisiert von morgens um sieben bis
abends um elf
oft ist sie erschöpft doch nun steht das
von ihr entworfene gebäude
[Musik]
sie bringt spielsachen zum kindergarten
alles spenden aus der schweiz
rund um das haus wird noch fleißig
gearbeitet auf partner ellas packt mit
an
morgen ist bereits die eröffnung die wc
schüsseln werden noch eingebaut für den
wasseranschluss reicht es aber nicht
mehr im wege center branche jeder
dortmund mit erwarte einfach hoch
law gehört zum beispiel jetzt von dirk
hoeren machen wenn ich viel spaß mit ihm
jeden tag wirklich einfach vorweg die
sturmflut am besten jetzt wo der
kindergarten gebaut ist und marias
energiereserven schon fast erschöpft
sind steht noch ein letzter kraftakt an
das eröffnungsfest ein wichtiger anlass
für die menschen hier in klappt das mit
dem gepäck
es braucht reis morgen es braucht
unbedingt eine anziehende erst mal
organisieren und es wird so sehr durch
ist ganz klar und das ist das risiko
wäre so schlimm
celebration wenn du am ersten tag ein
kleiner snack mäßig und sie sind jetzt
drei unesco komitee in afrika
[Musik]
in den spenden kartons aus der schweiz
findet marielle einen kleinen
erinnerungsfetzen an die alte heimat
[Musik]
wenn sie jetzt jeder großen drehen jetzt
für sein egal wenn die denn ist dann
also mit kriegen wir so schweizer fahne
hand schließlich verdanken wir der
kindergarten maria hat deshalb beim
schneider extra eine grössere schweizer
fahne in auftrag gegeben
die letzten vorbereitungen für das
eröffnungsfest laufen einmal mehr nicht
alles wie geplant
sonst lassen wir das mit den stühlen und
allem dafür haben wir schlicht keine
zeit
die schweizer fahne wird geliefert
marielle hat genau skizziert wie sie
auszusehen hat die abstände stimmen
nicht aber das ist nicht schlimm das ist
nicht mein größtes problem
sie hetzt weiter zu den köchen
[Musik]
es fehlen noch einige zutaten marielle
verspricht diese noch heute abend zu
besorgen
[Musik]
ich möchte einkaufen eine flotte und das
konto wirklich meint ich war stärker vor
sind wir belege dass man höflich und die
andere variante gesprungen und logie wie
das man kümmert aber das ist jetzt sehr
afrikanisch ich bin eine schiene für
moon war geht auf die afrikanische art
noch ist genug luft im schlauch wie
immer fällt marielle als weiße frau auf
sie muss aufpassen dass sie als westler
in nicht so viel bezahlt beim einkauf
das ganze mehr für einen preis machen
maria möchte schleunigst ins bett damit
sie morgen für den großen eröffnungstag
genügend energie hat
[Musik]
zwei jahre aufopfernde arbeit heute
endlich ist die einweihung des
kindergartens
auch die stühle sieht noch eingetroffen
dank vermochte aber das ist eines der
meditation in seiner loge und das gehört
einfach dazu
die zahl ist ein objekt für die letzte
dekorationen und letzten angriff es
kommt tatsächlich das ganze dorf auch
ein politischer würdenträger tauchte auf
der präfekt von st-etienne der
zweithöchste regierungsbeamte der
regierung
marielle hatte mit ihm noch nie etwas zu
tun
[Applaus]
[Musik]
erschöpfung oder die aufregung
die nerven liegen blank bei marillen
möchten sie auch etwas sagen zu eröffnen
ja klar ich arbeite zwei jahre lang für
diesen kindergarten und dann soll ich
keine ansprache halten
und natürlich dürfen sie reden ich
möchte wissen ob sie beide etwas sagen
möchte
aja elas soll auch etwas sagen erst mal
ein gleichwertiger partner
[Musik]
wir begrüßen die repräsentantin unserer
schweizer partner wie die schweizer
repräsentantin heißt ist wohl irgendwo
in den akten untergegangen
unsere schweizer partnerin marie l war
sie wird nun zu uns sprechen wir sind
heute hier für die eröffnung des
kindergartens zwei jahre haben wir dafür
gearbeitet und jetzt ist alles bereit
ich bin glücklich dass die kinder nun
zum ersten mal in die zimmer kennen
nach dem feierlichen zerschneiden des
eröffnungs panders folgt das essen mit
dem reiss hat es irgendwie doch nicht
geklappt
was schätzen sie den track der
verdienste im auto workers doch
was marielle nicht weiß während dem sie
ist werden die kinder entgegen allen
abmachungen bereits in ihre
klassenzimmer geführt und danach nach
hause geschickt als marielle davon
erfährt aus die enttäuschung aber auch
der ärger groß
sie machen was sie wollen sie eines
tages baum zu gast und mit dem auto bis
sie wollten dann können die erste mal
dass ich habe mich das gerücht war man
vom zu oder seid ihr denn zwischen und
das duo gewesen zu sagen die
einheimischen feiern weiter sie wissen
nicht um marie es frust für mario ist
das fest jedoch gelassen nein ich fühle
mich einsam hilflos ausgeliefert
jäger leider auch kein mensch versteht
da bin ich in die pause es hätte
attraktion als unternehmer und der
bissige pump aus zwar mit einem
kindergartenprojekt rosenmachen und am
touristische not die idee zu
unterstützen und der merkez-moschee
anderer mensch der mich versteht
demografin einfluss stapler muss kaufen
um ihn übersprungenen die freude
mitteilen
ich weiß gar nicht mehr was machen mit
gesprochen auch nicht
und dass mein geschäft
[Musik]
[Applaus]
am tag nach der eröffnung gerd marielle
noch einmal zurück zum kindergarten
er ist schon in vollem betrieb
für die kinder hat sie die viele arbeit
auf sich genommen
die kleinen jetzt fröhlich zu sehen ist
balsam für ihre seele
ich bin jetzt muss ich sagen wenn das
ist ja das könnte sich jetzt warum wenn
denn besser zwei super läuft mit dem
kind und die autoren geben brauchen das
geht bei uns schöne beziehung gefährdet
sieht wer weiß also gleich nämlich dank
nie wieder
[Musik]
aber erst einmal will um ariel futter
sich erholen und das leben liebe senegal
ging ist und das ist nur möglich ohne
ein projekt
messi
[Musik]
in kanada und unser wachstum in ihrer
nächsten station
clearwater
die kanadisch mentalität ist sicherer
als die afrikanische kontinent aber als
verzehnfacht laufen bei mir zum beispiel
lieferte bürokratie kroaten wird familie
folgt man vor zwei jahren ist es ein
dickeres großdemo sie beschäftigen
das sind einfach immer noch nicht wisse
ob sie wirklich dass kanada blieben
[Musik]
jetzt einfach mal davon haben verrät /
aids nicht zum glauben es nervt
die volks mussten sich oft nerven
während ihrer auswanderung schon als sie
noch in einem blockhaus in der schweiz
lebt im zürcherischen bänken beginnt ihr
langer kampf mit den kanadischen
behörden um ein wiesel völlig
überraschend wird der antrag für eine
aufenthaltsbewilligung im sommer 2015
abgelegt simone volk ist kunst ernährt
genau das erfüllt was event mehr bringen
eine kapitalmehrheit firma mir schaffet
viel arbeitsplätze mehr hände innovative
technik wo sie darüber gar nicht kennen
aber unbedingt buch hat mir einen
vertrag und wir wissen einfach nicht was
jetzt dort rein passt das ist einfach
das kann jemand verstorbene unternehmer
damit gerechnet
das haus ist verkauft ja mehr noch schon
fast komplett geräumt
[Musik]
als zwischenlösung bis zur auswanderung
wohnt die familie bei simones eltern
meint sich die ganze existenz der
maschine kauft nur für das ist doch
genau denke ministern klappte
volkswillen kanada forstwirtschaft im
steilen gelände betreiben
auch die teuren spezialmaschinen haben
sie bereits verschifft
aufgeben ist keine option mehr denn
nochmal der antragsteller und diesmal in
papierform
ja weil wir dürfen nicht auswandern weil
sie es uns abgelehnt haben
und jetzt mal alles nochmal in
papierform schicken will
diese wand rechtsberater meinte dass ich
die möglichkeit dass es dann halt
vielleicht nicht akzeptiert wird
prinzip hoffnung bei simone und
christian volk der sechsjährige sohn
john nimmt das alles unbeschwerter
refused ist replaced by so bietet luxus
letzte mal war ja geschlossen und
reviews reviews dinge und dass sie
einfach in bearbeitung ist überraschend
schnell erhält die familie doch noch ein
visum
[Musik]
die volks ziehen um in ein riesiges
kanadisches landhaus weshalb der antrag
zuerst abgelehnt wurde und dann doch
bewilligt die familie weiß es nicht
die entscheide der kanadischen
bürokratie sind hunger gründlich dies
werden die volks noch zu genüge zu
spüren bekommen denn bis jetzt haben sie
erst ein temporäres arbeitsvisum
christian nimmt die arbeit im wald auf
seine firma hat sofort zahlreiche
aufträge
[Musik]
simone bemüht sich um die dauerhafte
aufenthaltsbewilligung dem sogenannten
permanent resident
[Musik]
doch die kanadischen behörden lassen
nichts von sich hören
[Musik]
christians und simones firma boomt sie
kaufen neue maschinen stellen
kanadisches personal ein und bezahlen
steuern volks sind die perfekten
einwanderer
wieder super bis 13
kleine vereine zu wenig
[Musik]
hier hallo da wäre es denn
sollte es einmal selbstständig sind aber
wahr
ok
zwischen reinen das denn ist ein
wirklich laufen
[Musik]
thank you for your interest to have
shown in kanada der satz zwischen hohem
oder er sagt sich wirklichen hohen bei
mir das permanent resident die woche mit
den ist eigentlich die konsequenz dass
mit nächstes jahr also die meisten
müssen nächstes jahr am 18
russland wieder verlor
will der network visa ausläuft
naja es ist wie ein schlechter witz
ja ich weiß dass anni war mit seinem 8
im rechten fuß wieder geschrieben
[Musik]
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kauft ein volks ihres hauses vfl noch
nie soviel heinz per mail verrotten und
es gab große neuigkeit und mit
aufenthaltsbewilligung zu regeln
[Musik]
du und die ganze familie
du bist du ganztag verknüpft ganzes
glück ja
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
blendet die ganze schweiz wird gemüse
landvolks endlich die offen teils
bewegung dürfte dem kran oder blieben
ohne gibt's der neuigkeit endlich
raschen da wie es eigentlich gerne haben
wenn hier mal da die überkaufte
persönliches interview in vancouver und
denkt ja nur gut ich halt wieder einmal
das interview was wiederum mit birgit
und dann wird wieder mit papier bringen
und weiß nicht was bei uns immer die
e-klasse und du so gelaufen
ich finde ich irgendwie da kommt wieder
akzente denn ist es dir deine ist nur
dass die ist der der wende kam zunahme
des yorkshire des honorars etage machte
aber du weißt einfach witzig das duo
francesca vorher immer unter druck
alles baut investiert hat hat es
irgendwie immer im hinterkopf kaya und
war wieder und jetzt ist zwei wochen vor
der geburt wurde lisa ein volksbewegung
über so viel glück ist so hoch zu ziehen
wie so viele kopien mag sich ja krieg
wie ich ja jetzt nicht sofort wird er
grüßt sich wenn das frühjahr kommt aber
dann hab mal gesagt jeder kriegt ein
geschenk wenn wir den termin at haben
es wurden ja dürfen trotz
bewilligungsrunde alkoholen einzige
chance zu gehen kriegen dienst gottes
[Musik]
linie familienausflug zu einer der
schönsten bleibt sie die gegend
jetzt mit rufen teils bewilligung im
sack erfolgs ihres leben unbeschwert
genießen wenn das ist ein zitat dafür
selten vorkommt
[Musik]
der rechte an dem profi tour mit seiner
holzfäller viewer
[Musik]
das sind herrn 500 1 4222 ihrem alter
leben volks ganz in der nähe wohnt ist
noch mal eine andere kategorie rundlauf
dass er wirklich alle hits lee jeka
daheim sie ist es zu übungs und mache
und also mit dass er jetzt tagelang muss
dort sie sondern einfach dass man sich
ab und zu hatte luxus kann er dass er
seit jahren bin jetzt nochmal der bin
ich daheim machen ist umso mehr und es
ist schon besser wie er mag sein aber
das wäre schön wenn das nach pizza oder
ich es realistisch ist meine bank
im moment ist es auch so dass ich die
maschine war am besten schon am start
sind wohl die amerikaner verstehen gibt
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
es nicht die motive mein xi aber am
gleichen strick ziehen
besonders bei mietern antritt
ich bin wieder rot und wechsele letzten
auswanderer familie hochschulen sind die
einzige und mit walter urteilt prinz
albert ii auf der anderen seite von rock
melden die gegen das projekt vor der
landwirtschaft hälfte vom fleisch von
kanada wird dort produziert die
regionale spezialität beef jerky das ist
doch fleisch in allen variationen
[Musik]
dr
das führe holt euch das gemacht von hunt
sicherheitshalber sei welche möglichst
knappe für die nex die ganz neue
geschichte der jubiläumssendung zu rufen
auch kanada wenn sie sich könnte das
neues land zu bleiben nun suchen oder
australien oder skandinavien das sind ja
so sehen dafür aber es gibt ein charity
events ganz neu und anders die recht
exotische orte mir zum teil sogar mit
wild card führen wo sich familien ball
rollt daher ist das familie palma das
sind fritz und prägt auch mit dabei
bringt kindern natalie frau ziehen und
schon die familie lebt in belize
mittelamerika und das hat sie fritz zu
verdanken dem familienoberhaupt fritz
wuchs auf einem bauernhof im kanton
zürich auf er träumte schon als kleiner
junge von der großen weiten welt kaufen
weil ihr ehemann im schlafzimmer
doch fritz wurde 52 bis er endlich die
partnerin gefunden hatte die bereit war
mit ihm zusammen auszuwandern
brigit mutter von fünf kindern die
beiden hatten sich 2008 auf einer online
partnerbörse kennengelernt
eine späte liebe mit weitreichenden
folgen die beiden lande zusammen auf
einem anderen kontinent ins weiden
kanton zürich kasten wir 2012 die
patchworkfamilie ballmer kurz vor ihrer
abreise nach belize und vorstand dass
olic reagiert
und dann haben wir das mal überhaupt nur
genau das ist eigentlich mal um
natürlich sorgt dass er in ruhe duschen
sauber zu machen wie sich ein kampf
findet sich auch ganz offen buchen als
familie zwei wochen eigentlich verbands
von nord bis süd ag sagt und aber nach
sagte fritz zum im job trotz immer das
land doch wirklich viel haben geben und
ich schauen also überwachtes sie aber
schlagen das ist eigentlich das buch
krieg sie wo mir und das ist großes kino
[Gelächter]
der plan palmers wollen eine bäckerei
eröffnen die maschinen dafür kaufen sie
schon in der schweiz ihr ganzes hab und
gut packen sie in einen container
und wandern am schweizer
nationalfeiertag 2012 in ihrer neuen
heimat beließ 1
die familie hat vorerst nur ihr gepäck
der container ist noch unterwegs
[Musik]
aber das haben wir größten wert auf der
luftmatratze und dann der große schock
kommt erst später für die einfuhr ihres
hab und gut zahlen sie trotz
vorabklärungen 20000 franken mehr als
budgetiert
er hat schlussendlich blechen ballmer
als doppelt so viel wie ein
einheimischer
dafür besitzen sie nun ein riesiges
stück land größer als sechs
fußballfelder gleich neben der
hauptstadt von belize bhopal
und doch leben die ballers mitten im
dschungel diesem dschungel das land zu
entreißen ist eine aufgabe die fritz
seit sechs jahren in atem hält
jasmin ewigen war ist dieser krieg zu
gewinnen obwohl er körperlich härter
schuftet als noch als betriebsleiter in
der logistik ist fritz hier glücklicher
kreis in der schweiz
ich möchte einfach schlichtweg dann
wurde alles ist limitiert für alles gibt
es zwei oder drei sätze für alles blech
und und das ist ja alles nicht hier hat
fritz die muße auch die kleinen dinge zu
genießen das ist eine hauptplatz
niedermeiser
[Gelächter]
was für ein brot möchten sie probieren
wir haben verschiedene sorten ich bring
mal eine auswahl ein potenzieller kunde
ist dann trat in berlin bereits erinnert
dass mehrere die bäckerei befindet sich
in diesem kleinen häuschen region sony
ist hier der chef
damals haben keinen verkaufsgeschäft
sondern die für nur auf bestellung an
supermärkte und hotels
in der küche machen francine und
batterien ihre aufgaben
francine geht noch zur schule natalie
schloss die high school im fach
wirtschaft als klassenbeste ab und
studiert jetzt wirtschaftswissenschaften
an der uni sie hat einen freund
natalies freund giovanni ist in belize
ein velo champion
er wurde dieses jahr landesmeister im
einzelzeitfahren der sohn des nationalen
sicherheitschefs träumt von der tour de
france geht ist wie eine mutter für mich
sie unterstützt mich in allem auch dem
rad fahren und ich wollen demnächst
heiraten
[Gelächter]
giovanni fährt nun für ein paar tage ins
trainingslager
so hat die fünfköpfige familie für einen
moment wieder mehr platz
neben den vielen tieren die auf der farm
leben
[Musik]
b 214 sagt das sehr spezielle daher dem
aus fünf jahrhunderten hat ihn ja jetzt
schon so viele ausgang müssen dann raus
raus nehmen wir den ohren
[Musik]
da in der hauptstadt beim u bahn wird
heute der tag der unabhängigkeit
gefeiert
[Musik]
die mieten der parade bringt tochter
francine sie führt ihre schule ganz
vorne mit an
in belize wohnen keine 400.000 menschen
sony liefert das gebäck aus die nicht
verkauften produkte muss schon die
zurücknehmen
das ist der deal mit dem supermarkt
in belize kennt man keine backwaren wie
bei uns johnny muss immer wieder hartes
brot essen
das ist auch so ein schweres business
suite virus probieren die produkte haben
es kam aber bis es probiert hat das
schauen wir auch nicht problem
diese weise betraut wurde
den kampf gegen die tortilla haben sich
die ballmers etwas einfacher vorgestellt
doch auch das nicht hacker auf der brot
findet seine abnehmer
naja schwein specki ich den rest es ist
kein volles leben dass die beim
massieren gesendet am verhungern und
verdursten aber wenn man immer nur
leckere ich habe familie den er noch nie
der sportkreis mannheim er hat große gut
dafür könnte das man harmonie kann
dominierte tandem-x du mir zu ihn so der
hund macht spaß ich bin ich brühe wagen
dann ist das schön ich genieße die
freiheit und ich sage das ist für mich
der richtung dass ich für mich richtung
lebensqualität pur
aber ich muss krampfer dafür
[Musik]
trotz geldsorgen im dschungel von belize
scheint es der familie ball marken zu
gehen
auf luxus verzichtet sie und lebt trotz
engem raum ihre große freiheit
viel ist es nicht was die palmers aus
ihrer alten heimat vermissen
im gegenteil sie schätzen das einfache
leben sich zusammen geschweißt das ganze
meine waren wir mitten und muss mit nur
der hund matura dann geht das nur mit
genannt welche zuwanderer hatten
eigentlich sich von ganz alleine was
laufen eigentlich begann zu trinken
freiheit
freiheit statt richtung
das passt gut zu der familie ruckstuhl
und jetzt gab's keine klären sie 2016
[Musik]
ruckstuhl svh ohne die vom klienten in
der provinz alberta
ich weiß von der rücksturz dass sie zwar
unglaublich viel platz im husumer hängt
aber doch eher niveau nick wo sie zu mir
sie lieben das es wichtig aus richtung
gibt eindruck stuhls august
schicksalsschlag klemmt es für beide
sind die ältere tochter josephine hätte
schwere erbkrankheit zum geburtstag
[Musik]
herkunft
das sind ja super gemacht jetzt nicht so
gut hunde danke vielmals alexandra do
ist da immer das empfangskomitee
accenture ja großartig sind die beiden
[Musik]
es ist alles andere als
selbstverständlich dass ist josephine
sowohl gott sieht geburt
stoffwechselkrankheit nur dank einer
stammzelltransplantation rassig hütte
gruppe das schicksal von der josephine
hat auswanderung von rücksturz prägt für
ihre behandlung sind normal zurückgeht
schweiz zum 12 12 kanada auszuwandern
[Musik]
der erste spitalbesuch für josephine
nach ihre definitiven auswanderung hallo
das kannst du du schaffst gesund und gut
aus gehört ich bin gespannt wie alles
gelaufen ist
den gibt es anlass zur sorge das herz
und die lungen sind gut die leber die
nieren
es ist gut da war flüssigkeit in ihrem
gehirn sagten die schweizer ärzte dass
es behandelt werden
sie sagten das ist auf dem letzten emery
besser aus wenn du dich gerade so wohl
fühlst dann wollen wir dich doch gleich
untersuchen
josef in leidet an einer sehr seltenen
krankheit namens hochlar syndrom
der stoffwechsel funktioniert nicht
richtig die gesamte entwicklung ist
deshalb verlangsamt schwachpunkte sind
unter anderem die knochen und die
gelenke wie eine prinzessin krone
es ist eine endlose krankheitsgeschichte
josef ihn wird immer in ärztlicher
behandlung bleiben müssen
hani
pauli
egal ob sie selber geduldig bleiben
jetzt noch kalt
ja
da
josef ins krankheit sollte jedoch kein
hindernis sein nicht doch auszuwandern
darin waren sich alexandra und martens
einig beide waren sie immer fasziniert
von kanada zudem sahen sie als bauern in
der schweiz keine perspektive
[Musik]
beim traditionellen branding wo die
kälber ihr brandmal erhalten ist markus
fast der einzige ohne cowboyhut
markus hat eine feste anstellung bei
einem großvater betrieb dass die
monströsen mähdrescher zu fahren
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die ersten kindheitsjahre waren streng
nun könnte sich mit ihrer schwester
elena das leben immer mehr genießen dank
der gut verlaufenden behandlung
der held ist der unbekannte
stammzellenspender ein held will die
familie nie kennenlernen wird ein
unbekannter der das leben der familie
ruckstuhl aber für immer reicher gemacht
hat
[Musik]
sie schenkt rom jetzt ist das ganze land
jedes jahr habe was auf der bank
[Musik]
er weiß gar nicht wann er es gemacht hat
sie hoffe aber aber es ist nicht klar
wie sie kennen lernen
[Musik]
markus möchte gerne eine kuh kaufen
die rub stuhls haben das ziel sich so
weit wie möglich selbst versorgen zu
können
mit gemüse eiern und auch milch
[Musik]
wieviel möchtest du für die kuh 3800
euro das ist viel geld
die schweizer presse die zwei ja
vielleicht 2 200
markus macht fotos und die angelegenheit
mit alexandra besprechen zu können
[Musik]
und jetzt wo es war also beide 4 jährig
bei bremen calbe rund 2800 stützpfeiler
letzten moment noch sehr weißt du ich
weiß jetzt wo mit latenten street am tag
beteiligung 15 liter am tag gehen 820
liter geht sie sich ja muss die hebel
der große traum der familie ruckstuhl
wäre es eines tages eine eigene kleine
farm zu besitzen
auf die große viel und elena glücklich
aufwachsen können mehr diarra gott
eindruck sie letztes jahr schon recht
gut gerüstet sie sind mit den vitrinen
ich habe noch frisches glas geht
[Musik]
josefin ist sehr stolz dass das so
klappt drittklässlerinnen die wahl ob
sie bis zum service rund um den
wartezeiten james kam in hälfte zwei
mehr laufen und der viel zu glauben sie
hat sich mir beschwert und besser werden
hat das vielleicht zog und sich so horn
ist ja also sie macht gott die
fortschritte schul und die bucht für
alles länger
sie ist so ich schränke klenk dass sie
in amerika sich selber alles kann nicht
einfach so gelang aber nach dass gott
auf ihrem rücken herunter allem schade
sie mal riesig ram wie sie andere fähre
gelegt sich selber auch noch sicher
markus macht es brat zu meetings liter
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
engagiert steigbügel holle dinge für die
die anderen räte ich apps wo speziell
josef in goodwood
es fördere beweglichkeit und trainiert
gelenk
[Musik]
auf mich wirkt josephine als ob sie
erstens bürger aber der markus
widerspricht mir ist erst für das buch
josefin weiteren operation arbeiten hand
lenkt knx werk mit ihrer sie wird immer
wichtiger dass die förderung punkten
dort liegt wenn es mit berlin ex
entfernen was aber wir sind einander
jeder monat mindestens einmal täglich
bei der winter viel mehr für check ups
und alles unter sich
und damit wird das label angesagt und
mittlerer unternehmen vor zuerst kommt
[Musik]
gebesee
früher morgen alexandra nur geht zu den
tieren
markus ist unterwegs zum geschäft
[Musik]
die fahrt zu der große weit sie
staatliches land wo drin daher von
marketingchef der moderator für programm
regelmäßigen abständen musste markus
kontrollieren mit dem tier alles in
allem wer sich für ein richtiger cowboy
gehört mit dem bus und jetzt 34 markus
auto passen die holt wenn dir vor 15
jahren pokals kanada als cowboy nicht
abgeneigt angefangen mit kanada also 46
[Applaus]
aber ich musste
markus majerus von bis zu 4 bei st
[Musik]
nachdem sind norm schlafen wird
alexandra dokument alexandra offenburger
hof aufgewachsen aber mit 16 hat sie
rebelliert und die schuss sorge zu
machen
säge aus rind ein jumper stocker ich
habe das gefühl ich weiß ja nicht darum
bringt die vita im leben die man haben
kann plane crash und die eine karte
setzen und in jener zelle kabarett
iraner wertvoll sind mit ihrem körper
sich ein anderer weg finden planer ihre
stäbe
knappe stunde 700 hektar groß sind und
sich neu gemischt als ich dann nach
[Musik]
am markt chips immer vorsitzende monika
es verletze
um falk machten verletzt das aber war
[Musik]
fremde monat früher ja hauptsache sie
prägt
immer wieder
[Musik]
irgendwo ist der haka bouzid als der
freund im juni überhaupt noch ruhig dort
nimmt prof
wenn man doch schnell war gibson jene
diese sind ja auch schnell schneller als
mit seiner 1 mobil
[Musik]
da sitzt du siecle
wartete wo sind hier unseren daumes
jahre jetzt helmut becker
sind doch selber schuld
da wäre sicher haben jetzt us
intervention die wortwahl
dumm gelaufen
[Musik]
markus und ich sind die mono tag und
herden kontrollieren
ist da was der opa sie um rossi ich das
schaffe ich auch was schnell der
getragene fasst die zum stimmen durch
darüber
[Applaus]
[Musik]
alles gut also ist er steht wurde markus
dort kanada hinter die us pläne
[Musik]
der kunde berger bitte hier entlang
zu beginn jetzt bringst du mama
engagement zeige ja gut ist
auch für die beide hunderte markus
präsenzphase fleisch über das nicht
hilft damit der jagd rief der höhenzug
gott wir ihre eltern ins neue
skateboards
hier bietet sich garantieren diese stört
die reicht ich glaube sie beschweren
sich hauptdarsteller oscars der
historiker sind als team
ich bin meistens noch jetzt perfekt
genau und sie macht war da oft heißt
dass es den kompliziert wird und ewig
gott und ich bin dir wurden wird das ist
gut und wir machen wir so eine
mittelmacht findet aber schon weg war ja
nicht normal
[Musik]
zwischen probieren
aber jetzt eine längere ding machen hier
war vorhanden
ja was soll wir machen
ich werde daher von der arbeitskreis
malaga sid
das sind in china stoß zu bieten
langsam langsam
machen vieles verwirklichen
fermino richtig gepackt objekt bis zum
druck stuhls
sie hängt nur kreis eigentums rainer
bursche krise sind einfach viel zu
quirlig steckdosen calgary sich heute
umgebung gern ferienhaus liegt aber das
muss nicht nur schlecht sie traurig aber
auch etwas mehr freiheiten will man
wenig erfahrung mit weniger ja aber ich
sage wir werden sowieso hier erreicht
denn herr momentan wieder seine nächste
plan wenn man maschinen der firma dem
normales heimbach ausmaßen verstrahlung
die neueste plan sind dieses baumes noch
der drei jahre des flotten greifarm und
australien ende märz geht es nochmal ein
kleiner ruckstuhl
[Musik]
zurück zum nördlichsten punkt unserer
reise zu der endlose wälder vor ort und
seine bewohner
[Musik]
ich habe familie schönbächler
versprochen dass ich noch mal
zurückkommen und ihnen ein
überraschungsgast mitbringen
[Musik]
nein
mit dieser ums wanderer sendung was die
meisten nicht verziehen
das wird fürs fernsehen extra eine neue
version mit zeigen zum ersten mal viel
material wie der song entstanden ist
[Musik]
liga
[Applaus]
mit dem lied verbindet der köhler aber
harmlos mit 5 und der träumt selber
immer wieder von auswanderer auf
australien neuseeland kanada oder
wenigstens mal mit dem schiff punktuell
macht etwas besitzt aber noch nicht
im ressort general store mit dem goethe
und seine ganze familie in not gemacht
schließlich sei häufig unterwegs mit die
ganze familie ist nicht weg ist die
chance teil kanada aber ich habe anfangs
ist ein geschäft über 80
[Gelächter]
die beiden verdächtigten
außer mehr auf die kanadier mit dem
eigentlich das jetzt rechte regierung
hier war so ich dachte immer dass der
kölner seite kaum fernsehen aber der
hermann schoch und auch ziemlich sprüche
die ultimative landes qualität
foto lukas barth
[Applaus]
thomas wendt abzweig zu der familie
schönbächler hindere
derzeit stammen ist unklar weil die
pflege
was können wir dafür entstehen also okay
das ist das ist mona darum bat alle
würden
[Gelächter]
ja ja ja ja ja endlich live doch dies
konnte jetzt uns in die augen geblickt
allerdings ist sie was ich traue ihm
grund noch stabil
[Gelächter]
nicht dass jetzt die irgendwie ganz fest
würde mit bier
das ist doch dass wir körperlich als
auch leider ja aber wenn ein kind 10
berührungsängste und man findet schnell
gemeinsamkeiten sie schließlich am
hockey sich auf 800 mal drei monaten ein
mentalist premier stromanschluss kam aus
los
alte poststraße muss ich selber
schrauben weniger als auch das habe ich
gar nicht das anliegen ist ja es ist das
pc spiels wurde
er störe danny modell ermöglicht
wegbrennen es hatte bis hin zu betrieb
und du greifen muss man ja ich hab mir
da hier das ist das was ich aber nicht
sagen da herzlich von den heads of
oxford bock schoss genau aber es stimmt
für die große und die kleine hand
der abenteuerspielplatz durch ein traum
für alle vier töchter von köhler und der
heidi die filets li und was entweder zu
einem neuen trauen wir sagen ja ja ja ja
sagen es geht
es kommt ja meistens team morgen ist
morgen luca was geht ja richtig
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der gülle führe dies im abschluss aber
halt vom thunersee mit holz und muss
dafür immer mal wieder stände und uhr
also packte chance auf ihre
weiterbildung in sachen baumfällen denn
diplomierte forstwirt und meister vor
allem hätte sagen am hermann
[Musik]
was wir sind
du musst hier nicht und würde nicht
limitiert auf die hartz iv hat da
[Musik]
ja
so oft versichert durch besser gibt eine
ausbildung machen aber setzt sich aber
da muss natürlich auch von profis für
profis war hier hat im sommer schon noch
kommen ist heimstark
die studien
[Musik]
der nahm zeigte köhler im espace so
macht nämlich verschoben
und beim buch
[Musik]
prof
nein
red
vor der morgen rufe sorge darum heißt
die zugspitze noch keinen account
[Musik]
das nicht
im schnitt funktioniert die durchsagen
zwei jahren gleich sein zweites leben
die aus dem ruhrgebiet
ja
[Musik]
brennholz 16 uhr
so habe
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dort geht der weg zur die viel action at
home okay
[Musik]
und danny rund 1 hatte köhler 0 bis zum
lösen
[Musik]
wie hätte hermann seit gibt wären könnte
köhler offen sie ist durch besseres
bochum tour und steigt jetzt live am
markt warum hätte ich bin hier mit dem
anderen kratzer ständig verschwand und
heißen poppy ja es ist aber noch
ich glaube gar nicht so einfach wenn ich
gegen konkret ich heute überhaupt dass
man ihr job kostet dürfte sehr schell
ist mit csi
nach und nach hat gerade ist vielleicht
bin ich liebe ist das richtige klima ja
deswegen wir das wirklich
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
ich habe
us dollar
[Musik]
bevor hier
sie stiegen die bürger nicht davon
[Musik]
das neueste handy vor
ich brauche
[Musik]
hubert
die kinder hat
jeder zeit und kräftig
die nägel vor hier
[Musik]
muss sich jeder bürger mit der buchung
ich bin das neueste modell vor
naja sie stieg jeder bürger erhält
[Musik]
ich finde es nicht herr wurde vom
euro
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sie wandern aus oder sie kennen jemanden
der aus wandert auf und davon sucht
menschen die sich bei ihrem großen
abenteuer begleiten lassen
schreiben sie an auswandern als srf
punkt ch